comment ces milliers de partisans de
l'ex-président Jaïr bolsona auront pu
envahir aussi facilement la place des
trois pouvoirs à Brasilia
pourquoi la police personne ne les a
empêché de monter sur l'esplanade du
congrès ou pénétrer dans les bureaux des
députés pour tout saccager comment
a-t-on pu les laisser briser les vitres
et détruire les meubles et les œuvres
d'art inestimables du Planalto le palais
du gouvernement puis de la Cour suprême
de l'autre côté de la Grand-Place les
dégâts sont considérables
nombreux sont ceux qui pensent que la
police est en partie complice le
gouverneur du district fédéral a été
suspendu pour 90 jours et la capitale
Miss sous tutelle le président Lula n'a
pas marché ses mots ce sont des
fanatiques des nazis des stalinistes des
fascistes qui ont fait ce que personne
n'a jamais fait dans l'histoire de ce
pays
les habitants de Brasilia n'ont pas
apprécié et on en
pas d'accord c'est du vandalisme de
cette femme
je n'ai pas voté pour le président de ce
jeune homme mais c'est ridicule absurde
la démocratie doit être respectée
à Brasilia il faut revenir le plus vite
possible à la normale après avoir
constaté les dégâts le président Lula
convoqué son cabinet et les leaders des
deux chambres il s'agit de punir les
coupables et les complices on parle de
hausser les peines des militaires ou
policiers qui portent atteinte à l'état
de droit
les soldats ont démantelé le campement
des manifestants installés dans la
capitale depuis deux mois
même chose à Saint Paulo
et à Rio au grand dames des occupants
qui soutiennent que l'élection leur a
été volée et que Lula est un voleur
[Musique]
bien que l'ex-président bolsonaro est
désavouée les actes de violence et n'est
pas appelé à un coup d'état c'est
partisans continuent à réclamer un
retour à la dictature militaire
Jean-Michel Leprince Radio-Canada
Montréal